[Music]
all right so truth is there really is
only one spec of the iphone 14 that i
find really interesting right now but
first a question
are we at
peak smartphone i mean at this point
it's a classic question and the gut
reaction is usually yes feels like we
are but i've always said no we are not
at peak smartphone just as long as
things are objectively getting better
every single year just getting slightly
better over and over again we keep
getting more processing power more
memory higher resolutions and more
intelligence and we keep getting new
features recently there's cameras
underneath displays and fingerprint
readers underneath screens that are
getting better and just recently we
started getting phones folding in half
so if we are defining peak smartphone as
having reached the apex where phones are
no longer getting better and it's flat
then amazingly we're still not there yet
but i think we all have the same feeling
which is clearly they have slowed down a
lot since the beginning the 2007's and
2009's early smartphones were making
huge leaps you know i got the first hd
screen and then the first selfie camera
and then the first 8k video now we're
getting little things it slowed down so
now it's the middle of 2022 and the
iphone 13 is eight months old which
means there's already a bunch of rumors
about the next iphone coming right up
and just one of those rumors one of
those rumored specs stands out is really
interesting because
it's the same as last year so first of
all just fyi it looks like the mini
iphone will be gone and it will be
replaced actually by a larger version of
the base iphone and if i was a betting
person i'd say that's probably going to
be the most popular one so the iphone 14
lineup will allegedly be iphone 14
iphone 14 max
then iphone 14 pro
and iphone 14 pro max and we also know
that every year apple has a challenge to
try to differentiate between the pro
iphones and the non-pro iphones to try
to give you reasons to spend the extra
money to upgrade we've talked about
pricing ladders before in a video i'll
link it below like button if you haven't
seen it already so with the iphone 13
series the whole lineup was pretty solid
and there were a few differentiating
factors for the extra money the pro
iphone had the extra telephoto camera
plus lidar it had the stainless steel
around the outside the pro motion
display up front the extra ram the
higher max storage and a couple other
smaller features like pro res etc so
naturally some of these features are
enough to pull people up to a more
expensive pro iphone this year so the
iphone 14 has rumored to be a slightly
bigger gap between the regular iphone
and the pro iphone so take all the same
stuff that i just talked about with last
year's phones plus the new pro iphone is
rumored to be getting this new
pill-shaped cutout at the top for face
id and the selfie camera so finally
getting rid of the notch although it
really is just an aesthetic difference
it gets you some of those precious
pixels back and that's about it
and the pro iphone should get a new
higher end 48 megapixel main camera
while the regular iphone still sits at
12. now the pro will probably also still
bend to 12 megapixels but at least you
can get more detail out of it and
potentially higher resolution video but
the most interesting rumor of all of the
potential iphone 14 stuff
is that only the pro iphone
will get the chip upgrade so the iphone
14 pro and pro max will get a shiny new
a16 bionic chip and the non-pro iphone
14 and 14 max will actually have the
same one-year-old chip that's in the
phone i'm already using the a15 bionic
and this to me
is fascinating for so many reasons where
do i even start first of all when have
we ever seen two phones launch an entire
year apart with the exact same soc the
exact same chip in spec
i don't think we've ever seen that and i
think just out of principle hearing that
a lot of nerds and tech people are gonna
have a pretty big reaction like i feel
like i can basically see the comments
already like how can why would apple do
this how are they gonna sell us
basically the same phone with a new name
and try to pretend like it's something
new
so greedy of them so such an apple thing
to do but then again i can also kind of
see
all the defenses already too first of
all there's a chip shortage and shocker
no one is immune to it but then also
let's be real for a second if i handed
you a phone with an a15 bionic and
another identical phone with an a14
bionic
aside from running a benchmark how long
would it take you to actually notice the
difference
and it would probably take you a really
it would take you years down the line to
actually start to ever see a difference
there and really that's been a huge
feature of apple's super high-end chips
which is they give you these years of
headroom and so maybe it feels kind of
like you're shorting these new iphone 14
users of one year of headroom by not
upgrading the chip so yeah both sides
clearly have a point and it is very
interesting and a bit unprecedented to
have a brand new flagship iphone ship
with the same exact chip as an old
flagship iphone it just never happened
but
it does make a lot of sense we've seen
the a15 bionic is obviously a very
powerful chip and more than enough for
most normal people for a long time
and it is also very common for a
manufacturer to ship a slightly lower
end chip in their lower end phone so
high-end chip gets maybe the best
snapdragon 8 gen 1 or snapdragon 865
plus or whatever and then their lower
tier phone will have a lower tier chip
so for me i'm left with
one statement and one
question
the statement just being
the fact that i've been saying we are
not at peak smartphone yet
if apple does this
that statement does get a bit weaker of
course shipping the same flagship chip
although
they've said there are some rumors
saying there may be like two extra gigs
of ram alongside the a15 bionic so it's
not the exact same chip as last year but
you get the point that it's it's been
flattening very much and it feels more
than ever like we're at peak smartphone
but my one question is
how is apple gonna get on stage and talk
about the iphone 14
like it's not basically the same phone
as the iphone 13
right like unless i'm missing something
and there are some really big features
that i am not seeing yet that aren't
rumored yet
you know the apple way is usually just
praising their old phone all the time
because it's sold really well but then
selling it again with a new name at a
higher price just doesn't i don't know
if that's gonna work like you know how
every year on stage they have that slide
where after they reveal the price they
show the whole lineup of all the
different phones they sell at all the
different price brackets so this is how
that exact slide looked in 2021. i'm
trying to figure out what the 2022
version is going to look like so we have
the new iphone sc already with 5g that's
429 slots in the bottom there that's
fine
then i assume we'll have the new iphone
14 let's say that starts at 6.99 and the
14 pro starts still at 9.99
they can keep selling the iphone 12 with
the older specs for 4.99
but then do they keep the iphone 13
around for 5.99 can they do that i mean
what's the difference here what's that
difference for 100 extra dollars
you should never get the iphone 14 right
what's the explanation on stage going to
be are there some new iphone 14
exclusive software features in the
pipeline even though they have basically
the same specs maybe you'll get one more
year of software updates out of it than
a 13 maybe those two extra gigs of ram
will enable a little bit better headroom
and future proofing but
that by itself doesn't seem like it's
worth a hundred bucks so that is going
to be a really interesting detail to pay
attention to
you know what else is an interesting
detail to pay attention to
this lower third over here which comes
from the mkbhd plug-in that we just made
with motion vfx for final cut pro
premiere and resolve that's right we
have made our own video editing plugin
that i've been using and making stuff
like that and all kinds of stuff in our
video for the past couple weeks
the link is below i think it's awesome
if you're a creator fellow video maker
definitely check it out i'll put a link
in the description but yeah just a
little quick shout out to our brand new
video editing plugin anyway let me know
what you think of the way the iphone 14
is shaping up especially versus the
iphone 13 and how
those could differentiate themselves
aside from some new colors maybe
thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one and in the
comments section
peace
you